we're taking a second look this morning
at the first person ever to complete the
trans-canada trail it's the longest
trail in the world more than 16 thousand
miles spanning hundreds of walking paths
roads and waterways deanne whalen made
that journey on foot
bicycle and by boat it took her six
years that is commitment people jamie
wax talked with waylon about the things
she learned
they say to get to know someone
you must walk a mile in their shoes
but to really know deanne whalen and
what she's seen over the past six years
that track would take more than sixteen
thousand miles
you journeyed
to three oceans from the atlantic ocean
to the pacific ocean to the arctic ocean
yeah actually it went atlantic arctic
and then pacific in 2015 the 56-year-old
filmmaker set out for her hardest
expedition yet traveling the entire
trans-canada trail alone so long in fact
if you were to crisscross the united
states five times you still wouldn't
cover the distance of the trans-canada
trail the solo pilgrimage is the subject
of weyland's next documentary there's
something very fragile about being alone
out on lake superior or deep in the
woods after a while there's something
that wakes up inside you and you
suddenly feel more connected to life
than you've ever been do you come out of
the low depths of loneliness and
isolation into that moment i never
really was lonely on this journey i felt
a strong sense of connection to the
world that was around me the web of life
i went on this journey not as to prove
some sort of athletic accomplishment in
fact by day 10 i realized jamie that i
hadn't even gone as far as i thought i
could go in one day really right so i
burned my schedule and i joke with
people that that's the day i dropped the
rabbit suit for the turtle shell
and you know surrendered to how long the
journey was going to take me
no schedule to follow allowed waylon to
travel on her own terms taking breaks
when she needed a rest
when the weather was too dangerous
through her lens she captured the rugged
pathways and the tools she needed to
navigate the land
the water
and at times the treacherous conditions
on average she spent about eight months
on the trail each year nice to meet you
nice to be on your land along the way
whalen crossed paths with strangers so
she said never failed to offer her a
helping hand
and spent time in indigenous communities
whose ancestral land she was traveling
on that's where i actually found my hope
jamie
in learning a different way of different
relationship to the earth instead of
living on it living with it in a lot of
indigenous communities they think about
seven generations
every time you're making a decision you
think about seven generations into the
future how radical that would be if we
brought that into the corporate
boardroom or into government we're
telling our kids we care
on august first weyland's journey
finally came to an end her family and
the new friend she met traveling walked
with her hand in hand as she became the
first person and woman to complete the
entire trail what did it feel like on
mile zero i was definitely crying
and it wasn't because my journey was
over
it was because of all the kindness of
people when you watch the news sometimes
you're quite certain that the whole
world's full of sociopaths and it's not
i put myself in a very vulnerable
position being out there alone for as
long as i was and i met a lot of people
and not once did i not
meet kindness on my journey
weyland's next journey sharing the
wisdom she learned on her adventures in
a new book and documentary both titled
500 days in the wild nature is a place
that we could all turn to through our
isolation to fine healing i definitely
found my hope in human kindness
all across this land and in what
connects us where you know for all of
our differences we're all connected by
this land and by the water we are one
for cbs mornings i'm jamie wax in new
york
good reminder yeah no doubt about it
there's something called the new rich
which doing it's about doing things that
aren't about money it's about doing
things that enrich the spirit and that
journey right there helps change her
alone but not lonely because she was
connected
at birth i love that i met everyone with
kindness that's awesome i know this
world what are we going to do
i know that's sort of an indictment of
us the media that's what she was saying
all right